[Music]
in ninja guards news hmm
submitted by a double-double Boppity
Boppity better in and out reference it
could be a basketball reference oh I
didn't even know that well I do like
basketball I just don't know nothing
about it a Japanese security firm plans
to provide actual ninja security guards
for the 2020 Olympics thank you I was
about to ask a question yeah I watched
the turtles you have it there's ninja
theme parks yeah but it's it's totally
cosplay like it's not real yeah so then
this guy's making it up there aren't
gonna practice ninjas there are but it's
a joke like I mean okay so like it's
almost like this it's like it's like a
tourist thing right where there's these
ninja martial arts schools but it's
literally like all these Europeans or
white people they're like trying to
learn how to and there's like it's
almost like they're going into like a
con like and there's these ninjas that
are teaching him like like martial arts
and whatever but then or they don't know
em hmm
do they know or don't go I don't think I
think they take it seriously but for
Japanese people though that that those
ninjutsu schools they don't really think
that they're real yeah they're kind of
like mmm because the way that I don't
know the way that it's supposed to
evolve is into the actual military like
what we see now Navy SEALs all that
stuff those are the real ninjas right
but it's it's funny so there's theme
parks there's like cosplay there's all
that stuff and there's a lot of videos
on YouTube of ninja schools you could
pretend to be a ninja but you don't see
any Japanese students I think for the
Olympics I'm just sweaty dudes in
fedoras part of the Olympics though is
to like show your country the history or
a theme or even like you said like even
though it's kind of fake but it's kind
of real like to put that out there it's
a fable or like it's like yeah folklore
yeah what was the origins of ninjas
they're Chinese so like the the history
of what ninjas like not the way that the
Americans know of ninjas or like the way
that ninjas are on anime but the real
real ninjas is so back in the day
samurai had to fight face-to-face so
espionage the spying things
assassinating all those things were
considered really really low-level
behavior so what they did was they got
so you know by that time China was a
huge Empire so they had a huge
militaries they had these types of
tactics of spying and all that so they
would employ special force guys from
China and they would use that to kind of
like up against the other they were
kinda like maybe SEALs yeah they work
basically but then there are private
military contractors but in Japanese
culture though during that time fighting
like that was like lowest of the lows so
you know how like there's just rules of
engagement right so like if you're a
warrior or you had to be known that like
you are the warlord where your guys go
out into the field as tough guys and
fight one-on-one now saying these ones
are sneaking around your back they're
sneaking around yeah yeah but people are
still doing it but that's what ninjas
were so they were always like their net
they're never like this cool figure
there's smoke bombs there oh yeah they
were always these like shady little
sneaky you know they were really
respected then no no samurais were yeah
Oh cuz I mean what they're doing is
sneaky like they can't fight a man
face-to-face they have to kill them in
their sleep like what they're like how
we view scammers today exactly to like
armed robbery
yeah like the British viewed the
militiamen like George Washington as
homies Oh what the [ __ ] you guys doing
climate entreats shooting at us come out
into the field that should be face to
face a real man yeah I like that
yep yeah well there's this Japanese
security firm that they're hoping to
have their security officers be the ones
to be protecting like the Olympics in
2020 and so like they want to have their
security officers dressed as ninjas
modern ninjas so their toes gonna be
like this
I love those shoes Tabby's yeah they're
saying that they want to contribute to
the Tokyo Olympics and so ninjas are
world class icons and that they want
people to feel familiar with security at
sports facilities by seeing them dressed
as a ninja so maybe you know the history
you know Joe no no they know that the
anime ninjas in the in the current day
folklore yeah but people also know the
reality of it too that's Joe's probably
like us when we celebrate Columbus Day
we don't celebrate how many Native
Americans even murdered yeah yeah we
just celebrate the folklore of
Christopher Columbus you know people
like school they're trying it like
they're stopping
Yap celebrating and stuff oh that's
awesome opposed oh yeah that's
culturally sort of Columbus thing yeah
that's neat
I feel like I would rather it would look
more cool to have I mean it doesn't make
any sense and wouldn't be feasible or a
bright summer is so much cooler
it'd be so hot is it like it wouldn't it
wouldn't be efficient yeah be ah it
wouldn't be so sure that you meant like
attractive like everyone like in are
like like looking like it's like a
samurai cool be cool
well it wouldn't be efficient like if
something drunk unruly American like no
samurai is gonna run up there swinging
all over the place that carry him out
I'm gonna have tasers or something what
I'm not sure they'll just have their
swords I've seen these like so you know
how we have we're gonna commit murder
you know how we have those reenactors
right that like we're LARPing that
LARPers right so in Japan they have the
same thing action role play you seen the
movie role models yeah that does it
pretty good yeah that is paid so in
Japan they have guys that do the the
whole like reenactments they wear the
samurai outfits and all that but it's
like the geeks of Japan so they're all
like super overweight or super skinny
and they look I want it to be like the
fit military guys of Japan wearing it so
they looks like Last Samurai and you
have all these dope ass dudes like it's
the body's like a guy with like long
flowy hair
300 version of yeah do it they'll be
sick that will be better so if you had
your own security for me just have him
dress up a summary no cuz it wanted to
be very efficient like they can't like
if you can't bleed out you're just like
clinging around a gun and that looks
even worse cuz you can hear a plastic
baby there's a bunch of like Bulls
hitting each other they were kind of
cool though it would look cool even only
it'd be great for like a photo
opportunity but for loot for them to
actually do their job just makes sense
what about you Bart if you if you owned
a security firm and it had like a little
gimmick what would it be like well it's
just like real security or is this like
fake security like what do they do I
checked in your life are they there
Olympic they're gonna do some [ __ ] I get
flack let's say Michael Phelps gets
groped they're gonna jujitsu someone's
ass or are they just gonna buy hey stop
that are you talking about Michael
Phelps get gross I think they're more
worried about like like people puking in
the corner or terrorist attacks oh so
like like Logan Paul type stuff like
around the country I feel like these
ninja security are like the it's like
the target greeter security with the pen
oh your seat b12 oh you're gonna go to
over here let's just entertain whatever
however you want question security if
ever have to a security group like legit
real security guys I want to make it
really weird and just dress them up like
the really hardcore BDS and black
leather oh sick everywhere is that like
heels that like are so high it's like
[ __ ] on their toes no it's not even
to be kind of efficient something like
so they have leather chaps on in there
yeah alright I just want to like make it
look really weird so they got a latex
suit with a dick just dangling out
always just the whole here you don't
even see [ __ ] face Oh like the the
American Horror Story
yeah yes [ __ ] creepy yeah or maybe
okay so maybe not that far but maybe
like the maybe like that what is it what
is that why I am seeing
that's great fun all right Gina Tiffany
said how about you Bart because you
would just didn't go with the porcelain
with the floor what don't figure it out
just [ __ ] it roll with the punches go
with the flow
find it everyone's in have a surfboard
[Laughter]
surfboard security company alright
that's tight not for oh here's your
security company you look like you come
up with your own business plan what is
it then they're gonna be nurses that
Jack people off what [ __ ] dome yeah
because he big diffuseness it's like if
a terrorist comes I'm gonna [ __ ] blow
this [ __ ] up and then she goes wait you
guys about to get into a fight she goes
stop right now are they gonna even let
you approach them to even unzip their
pants well I mean like if a terrorist
this way police go freeze
you just get a hot girl BAM all guys
that's a girl criminal yeah girls
interesting you see like a terrorist
just thing almost suddenly he sees a
pair of boobs like wait hold on what
what am i that would beat that would
throw it off yeah but then if you became
really famous then they're gonna be
boobies are like we're not falling for
that anymore yeah
that's not these questions what the hell
how is he my imagination okay
well what's going on here today what do
they look like is there like a I just
pictured a [ __ ] ninja all black and
this [ __ ] big-ass belly you know like
you can get take a roll Japan does
things they do it all cute like their
cars are [ __ ] cute it looked like us
it's like a van that they just smash
like a soda can that's ready to be
recycled and [ __ ] and in the policeman
looked like 1940s like post office guys
and [ __ ] and so it's probably gonna be
some gimmicky [ __ ] you know well I do
have one photo and this is the photo of
they're all like this of the head of the
company and so she's saying like since
2016 she's been having like her security
officers dress as medieval warriors or
assassins and they're just trying to
take advantage of like the ninja tourism
cuz there's a lot of tourists that take
photos with them so there's a photo of
her just kind of happen I have commuters
cuz that's pretty dope that really is
that one [ __ ] fitted cap she is oh
that's weird why the [ __ ] you wearing
like this dump outfit and then a [ __ ]
fitted on top security guard just looks
like a ginger pretty much she's top
hip-hop half asian culture or something
you know they're kids a headband like
probably just showing them their seat
they're not like pulling out a gun make
a channel a b24 right over here whatever